how is it possible something that giant
comes out there it just looks like
something out of a sci-fi horror movie
that's not helpful Sam is the love of my
life
happy engaged me you guys have some
difficult news the blood test shows that
you are not pregnant oh there's this
moment when everything changes you have
a mess that is cancer this is the moment
at least we won't have to pay for
college this is a very smart to her
welcome to the last group you ever
wanted to be my brother I was a still
holding up I hope she keeps up with the
bird watching banging's welcome to group
grab a sit right there I feel
underdressed
alright guy does it helps does it it's
not dead yet so it's got to be doing
something like I'm just trying to find
something positive here your wig is
pretty it's my hair
this is a disaster who's gonna match
your socks I can take care of myself
what if you can't let me stay just
though let's be real
Sam's gonna be a chick magnet he's never
had to date too freaking pretty I
decided to conclude okay if you do got
better they're gonna feel like a real
ass you are not allowed to talk to me
like that I'm sick no you no no come on
that's not nowhere
she's kind of scared out of her mind
right now says it needs to know that you
were gonna be okay yeah but you serious
you don't have as much time as you think
you do it's true for you it's true for
every person on the planet all the
what-ifs are missing out on what is I
I planned your whole future it wouldn't
hurt so much not to be a part of it
[Music]
so the things we do for the people along
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]